[Applause]
leonard has had such a cultural impact
for over 50 years
he was a deeper poet and a director and
philanthropist
he's just an incredibly inspiring
individual
ironically he played a character who
didn't experience emotion in the way
that we do but he was the spirit of star
trek
science officer spot reporting has
ordered captain spock you haven't
changed a bit you're just warm and
socialized
he was a profoundly talented actor and i
know what he felt about this character
and what it meant to be
part of this world
looking back
what can we say about star trek and the
effect that it has on people who love it
so much
the impact is enormous and it's a
positive impact
he was an incredibly generous and uh
thoughtful man and he imbued that
character with so many of his finest
qualities and he lived a beautiful life
we should all be so lucky to live half
as fulfilled as he did
[Music]
you
[Applause]